Let's take a look at Muzei.
Muzei, is a live wallpaper application
that displays a new work of
art as your background every day.
If you go and check out the source code,
in addition to Roman,
you'll see Ian Lake
listed a number of times.
You might remember him from our advanced
Android App Development course with
Joanna and Dan.
Muzei, is a good example, because it
makes extensive use of dimensions files
to make its UI work on
multiple form factors.
So I went ahead and
downloaded the source code from the link
listed in the instructor's notes.
Now in this dimensions file, this is for
the tablet screen,
with the smallest width of 600 dips.
And we can see that we have a number
of dimensions listed in here.
We also have a general
dimensions file that lists many
of the same properties,
just with different dimensions.
Now, if we go to our activity, we can
see how we use these dimensions, so
instead of specifying the dips
right here, we're using @dimen and
then the name that was specified
in the dimension file.
Now Android Studio does
a couple of things for you.
So, sometimes you'll see
the dimensions like this,
where they're listed in green.
If you ever see a property that's
listing gray, that means that
Android Studio is showing you
the value that it's pointing to.
So if you hover over one of these,
you can see the dimension value that
Android Studio is pulling from.